hello everyone welcome to another
episode special episode today because
today we are going to walk through how
to
build from inception to actual
implementation
a music generator a music recommendation
system
yeah got that right so first we're going
to start with
a proof of concept just uh just a little
overview of what we're going to be doing
followed by like getting into each of
these individual components separately
it's going to be a long video but it's
going to be fun so just keep following
along if you can
um okay so first of all we have this
like piece of audio right now right
and then we want to pass it into this
embedding generator
so what an embedding generating
embedding generator does it
is it'll take your song and then it'll
vectorize it convert it into like a byte
vector of sorts right
and um and and then it takes that vector
and then passes it into a recommendation
engine because now machine learning
understands math
so this recommendation engine will then
recommend the closest values that are to
this original
music audio and so effectively we're
building a recommendation system or
recommendation engine
now in order to build all of these
components we have
three major resources that we use the
first is the audio set data set
which will provide us all the you know
kind of like the youtube videos
and all those you know resources in
general
then we have the max audio embedding
generator from
ibm which is a tool that helps you
convert
raw wav files into um
into a byte string or into like vectors
in general
and then we have anoi which is an
approximate nearest neighbors
implementation
by one of the guys from spotify and
what it does is it basically takes your
vector and then
spits out neighboring vectors and these
vectors can of course be translated back
into
music right and so
well that's actually the entire gist of
the video
we're going to be walking through each
one of these separately from audio data
set the max audio embedding generator in
annoy
and we're going to be walking through
certain examples how they're used with
code
so keep following along okay
so right now first is the audio set
right this audio side data set like i
mentioned it's a set of
youtube video ids it's kind of like this
massive
huge file which uh consists of json-like
information but it's not exactly json
we're going to have to do some
conversions and processing later
so let me just um let me just give you
an example
of a format so this entire json looking
structure
is of one sample video in
the entire corpus and like this entire
sample they have like
i don't know 13 000 of them so let's
just start with this like what does this
actually mean right
so first of all um it's saying that okay
we have a video id
which is right here now this video id is
basically like a youtube url
kind of thing you know youtube.com watch
whatever that id is
that is going to be here then start time
and
end time so basically it's saying okay
from this video id
we want to take the timestamps from six
seconds
in the video till 16 seconds in the
video and that 10 second chunk
is your music uh that's your frame that
you need right now
right next is that we have labels so
labels are kind of like tags that are
given to the video
it's like okay is this music is this uh
within music is a guitar
or is it like a man talking or a woman
talking or is this like a car horn
and all of these uh labels are kind of
stored in a list
and the meaning of these labels well it
says it can be found here but it's
actually
in a in a csv that i'll probably share
with you later and it's exactly like
what i said those tags could be
and then we have feature lists which is
basically saying
every second of audio or every part of
that audio is now
encoded into this 128
feature string so the thing is that like
let's say that we have like a 10 second
piece of audio
what it's doing is that we are chunking
that 10 second piece of audio into
like 10 chunks of one second each and
each of those seconds
are encoded into a 128
um basically it's an array of 128
numbers which is like a byte array
and so this is the first second of audio
this is the second second of audio and
like that we'll have like 10 lists
for every second of the audio
and yeah this is well that's actually
our entire data set like this it's
repeated maybe 13
000 times and it's a really big file if
you download it it's like 2.4 gigs right
you can get this entire data set by
clicking
on probably the us corpus yeah this link
right here
and then you just need to double click
and extract that
just extracted right and all of these
files
are essentially they are stored i think
i have it here yeah
so all of that is basically this thing
this audio set v1 embeddings and they're
stored in the form of tf records
so each of these records have exactly
well this kind of information for like
13 000 examples
and right now the the thing is that you
know
all of these features are like typically
when you look at music
raw wave data right um they're kind of
stored in
like you you see like cds for example
having 44.1 kilohertz which is like
saying
44 100 numbers are used to
they're used to represent like one
second of data
right but you know that's a lot to work
with machine learning and that's why
um the output of this right now those
120 features is a lot less
and it also represents the same amount
of information so this is the embedding
that we were talking about
right in the in the video in the in this
proof of concept right here
and these embeddings are actually
pre-generated by this max audio
embedding generator
um yeah and if
this so we don't really need to do any
of them we don't need to do the
embedding ourselves
they're already available in this data
set but uh let me just explain how that
embedding generation works
so let me come to this screen okay so
this i'm running um basically i built an
application i mean i didn't build it
myself but like
i'm running an application that i cloned
from the ibm max audio embedding
generator library and what they do here
is well you can basically let me just
show you
so i uploaded a wav file right oh this
wav file if like it's just like a car
horn
wav file and why am i saving this it's a
car horn wave file
and what's happening now is if you click
like
you know um if you click to execute this
it will return a response right here and
the response is the embedding
so like i said the embedding will be
generated for you know every second of
audio
this entire thing you see this list of
lists right this first list
until until here
is 128 numbers of bytes and that
represents one second of the car horn
like that this represents the other
section which is the second car
the second second of the car horn this
is the third second and so on
now uh i can i'm going to explain
exactly like how
you can uh render this so if you wanted
to
you could see i'm running this on like
localhost on port 5000 right
and in order to do exactly this you just
need to go to the
ibm's main repository was that yeah the
max audio embedding generator repository
you clone this repository and then you
follow the steps for
running locally right here so basically
clone the repository
go into their main directory then you
need to have docker installed which
will help you containerize the build it
helps you build
containerized applications so
applications that can kind of run on
their own with their own dependencies
just
all in one bundle right it's a good way
to build
applications these days and then you
just need to run
the model if you run docker run on port
5000
you will get and then go to your browser
and type in localhost 5000 you'll get
exactly this page
and you can play around with it just
just to see how you can upload wav files
and then see their corresponding results
so hope that is super clear
right now okay so we kind of got an
intuition let's see let's go back here
so we know what the audio
data set is for uh we know how to
actually embed now
the audio generating well at least we
know you know using this tool
how to create the embeddings so now we
have a vector
right but the thing is that like we we
don't wanna we have like thirteen
thousand of these vectors right i mean
thirteen thousand examples we don't want
to just like sit and keep doing it
for uh you know every single one of them
so the audio data set like i mentioned
already has the vec they've already used
the max audio embedding generator
but this is just for more for your
reference to understand what's
really going on what the data in the
audio set here
this represents so cool
yeah we're cool professor halthor
professor what
no way okay so
now um so within ibm you know
this i was actually here right uh sorry
if the explanation is jumping all over
the place because there's just a lot of
files to go through
the idea is just for you to understand
what's going on as long as you do
i'm satisfied so now you can run the
model like this with a fancy ui
but they also gave you know you see
these this little curl request that um
there's a little curl request if you can
see here right we can use that to pass
in
an audio file like a wav file via like a
terminal command
and then we can get the response too
right
and so what we can do is they have like
a demo notebook within this let me just
open that i think it's in samples
internet yay and then like there's demo
i pi and b
right so i'm not going to open it here
but i actually have it
i have it open over here yeah so that
that same notebook that you saw
is exactly what i've copied and pasted
here hence all the licensing information
is here
and what this will do is it's going to
read a wave file and get the
corresponding embeddings
like i just mentioned but via you know a
code interface
right um i'm i'm putting it here because
i made a couple of changes
just to make sure that the notebook
works properly but let's go through
exactly what this notebook is doing
um so first of all you're importing you
know just a bunch of like system level
uh you know libraries json
to deal with json data mount plot live
to just plot we have like a plot of a
chart coming up
um then like yeah let's see similarity
uh cosine similarity again for
for uh getting similarity between two
vectors
so cool uh also glob is used for
getting it's it's used for getting like
media type assets and fetching them
kind of like how here we're using to
fetch uh
fetch everything in a directory we're
going to fetch
the all the way files in demo assets
which was
basically all the all the stuff in this
repository right here so all of these
wav
files we are going to fetch right and if
we list out what exactly is being
fetched
you see right so it's like a wave file
of a jazz guitar a wav file of birds
chirping
away file of gunshots yeah
now the goal here is to convert these
wav files into the embeddings
using the max audio embedding generator
by the way just to make it clear you
know an embedding is basically an
array that has a representation of
the corresponding file that is coming
from
in this case the wav file and we just
require it
so that it's like basically essentially
a compressed representation that has all
the meaning of the data
and because it's more compressed we can
deal with it in machine learning or like
you know
in general right with like the nearest
neighbor approach whatever it is
that we're going to be using later all
right
so now coming to this little section
over here
so what we're doing is like for every
single wav file we're going to execute
this curl request
right what it's going to do is i'm
passing the audio wav file
and i'm passing it to that url that we
just uh
mentioned that we just put up right here
uh
and then what it's going to do is it's
going to run the prediction model which
is basically run it through
our embedding that embedding generator
and when it generates an embedding it's
going to output it to a json file
excuse me right and that
yeah that is basically the the format of
the response that we just shared
right now uh this is going to be like
let's say that you just
extract the embedding which is a list of
lists where each list within that list
is 128
um characters of bytes and now what i'm
doing is i want the audio
length to be cut at 10 seconds so let's
say that we have clips that are you know
some clips are
various lengths right but i only want
audio clips that are at least 10 seconds
and for those clips we cut it at 10
seconds
so that we have so we make sure that
every single audio clip
is the same size so in this case um
we're just going to have uh like every
if every single audio is now cut to 10
seconds
every single a list of lists so the list
of lists will basically contain 10 lists
and each of those 10 lists will be 128
um characters for bytes that's exactly
what's happening here
right and i'm just printing out every
single column making there's like 19 or
20 calls
and i'm encoding every single one of
those wav files that i printed above
into and embedding so now and what i'm
doing now is since it's a list of
lists right now of each of those lists
is a 10 cross 128
for every single sample i'm just
flattening it so now we have like a
single vector of 1280 dimensions
that represents a wav file cool
so now that it's a much compressed more
a much more compressed representation
we can do things like i don't know find
the cosine similarity between them so
that
that'll inherently give us like okay if
if we have if the cosine similarity is
higher
that means the two vectors are more
similar in meaning too
right and so i'm just testing out a few
values uh here
uh like i mean you'll kind of see these
later it's a value between zero and one
this is the cosine similarities so this
is like the first wave file this is the
secondary file
and their corresponding cosine
similarity it looks pretty good they're
pretty high values for
for for things that are similar like two
types of verbs or two types of guitars
right and now what i'm doing is well
let's print all of these
into um like a cosine similarity matrix
right and so what we have is this little
bad boy right here cosine similarity
between normalizing bettings
so x and y axes are you know the
corresponding
items that we're getting um higher the
better so what stands out here is like
here okay 0.89 is pretty high
for a jazz guitar what is 0.89 it's a
normal guitar
which is what we would expect a jazz
guitar is the most similar to a normal
guitar
and then for birds 2 well it's most
similar to birds one
look at that and then gunshots well 0.86
is the highest
here and that is excuse me
more similar to fireworks which makes
sense right
and so overall the embeddings that are
generated by this
uh max audio uh gener embedding
generator
are pretty good they're pretty good to
use and
yeah i mean like some of course like you
know some of these are a little higher
than i'd like it to be but
you know on a relative scale it works
for us
it's good enough and so yeah we can now
use this back to our proof of concept
here
we can now we now are able to basically
well have a set of these vectors and we
can now pass into recommendation engine
but of course i just did it on random
wav files right now
i executed on random wave files but we
need to execute it on our audio data set
which i do here right
so now we're gonna the objective of this
notebook it's a second notebook by the
way
called audio set processing where the
objective is to read that audio set data
that's in
a convoluted like those tf records
essentially and then we need to convert
it into just like a single json file
that will act as
our data set so this is the second of
the third notebook by the way
so you know what's coming so the
prerequisite is to download the audio
set data set
in that tar.z file make sure the
notebook is in the same directory as the
uncompressed embeddings
and then um and that is like basically
the same
folder level as the audio set v1
embeddings which was
this this little thing right here yeah
this folder
this folder cool right
so now okay so now i wrote this file so
i can explain stuff
right so we're going to be using some
tensorflow here so you want to install
that
uh the directory we want to be reading
is
all the all the tf record files that are
in
uh the eval folder now what i'm trying
to do is well if it ends in tf record
i'm just storing it into my data set so
this data set will essentially be like a
list
of tf record files i'm enabling eager
execution because you know tensorflow
has this thing where
i'm not sure if i require it right now
but when i was testing certain things
out
um tensorflow has a lazy method of
execution where it will like build an
entire tensor
graph i guess i forget what the
appropriate terminology is
and then like when it really needs to
form that execution
it will start executing only then and
eager execution is like what you would
typically expect like as soon as it sees
like a particular function even though
it doesn't need to execute
it will execute it so yeah i'm enabling
that here
um i'm converting it now since dataset
is a list of tf records
i want to just encapsulate it in a tf
record data set object
which i call now raw data set and now
well uh we have a bunch now all these
this entire data set could be
representative of
many types of audios in fact let me
actually show you
because like i have this there's like
class labels right
and i want to get all the labels that
you know it can correspond to so
essentially it'll look like this csv
file
so this these these are all possible um
you know labels that can be appended to
the audio data set that is all the
labels that can be
in so from if this is an example all the
labels that can be in this this value
region
right and that is what
exactly we are seeing here right so it's
88
response to clip-clop whatever that is
87 is the sound of a horse
and so on we have like hundreds of these
okay so what i'm doing is i'm reading
that csv file and getting those labels
and then i only want to extract the ones
we're only concerned with music though
right because this is supposed to be a
music generator
and so what you do is i'm only going i'm
doing like a string search for
everything that contains the word music
within those labels
and extracting them only
removing case sensitivity because
obviously
and so we have a set of music labels
that are stored here
right next now we are going to iterate
over
every single one now this is the main
meat of the code where
you know we're converting all those tf
records in that incorrigible form
to a json data set that is more
manageable
so okay so now we have for every single
tf record in this data set what we're
gonna do
is we are going to kind of like um
tensorflow has this internal object
called example
where it helps in serializing um tf
record data
and it creates something called an
example i'll probably put
this is a type of data structure in
tensorflow
and how to process tf records i have it
in the resources down here
you can click this link for tutorials on
exactly like how
and why i'm using this right here right
so anyways this is just to extract you
know that tf record data
now we know that there is audio metadata
associated with it
that audio metadata again i'm going to
keep referencing this
audio metadata being this this chunk
for this chunk the context right here
right
so that has like all the information
video id start time and time in labels
and that's going back here is exactly
what
i am extracting so we get the context
dot features labels
and then you know you just have to
follow the tree down in order to extract
the actual label value
in the form of a list so all the audio
labels start time and time video id
we store it all now when we store it
though i want to check
if this particular sample corresponds to
a music label right because
what this is essentially doing is like
it's going to do like an intersection
so um i just want to make sure that this
audio label like one of the tags at
least
it's gonna have several tags right at
least if one of them corresponds to a
music kind of tag
i want to include it in our data set but
if it's not
then forget it skip to the next one skip
to the next record
right and so uh hence that logic is
right here
now let's say that it is a music label
that's great now we'll extract the
feature the actual
audio embedding so that audio embedding
is the second part of this which is here
so you have to go down featureless
feature feature feature list
key is audio embedding and then get the
byte list for every second
which is exactly what i do here
feature yeah feature lists feature list
audio betting dot feature
and then yeah and for every feature we
get the byte list
right and that is going to be our embed
this is going to be like a list of lists
of course
you know um this is going to be like a
list of yeah each list is 128
of size right but of course um they can
be varying lengths because it depends on
the length of the audio
um but for the audio embedding that
we're going to use for our data set
we want to you know we want to truncate
it to just 10 seconds
num seconds is 10 seconds so essentially
we're just going to get the first
10 um lists in that list of lists
right and finally
what we're gonna do is well we are going
to see if yeah
so obviously the length has to be um
yeah that's fine
this is just going to be just to make
sure that uh the if the
if we're getting if we're dealing with
like shorter audio you know like six
second audio or three second audio
it's not going to be the uniform across
you know the other audio which is
clipped at 10
so if it's small audio we're just going
to skip
and then all we're doing is
encapsulating it into a little json
right here
we have the label the video id the start
time the end time and the audio
embedding which is going to be a list
now of
um this is a flattened list so it's a
list of one of
1 280 numbers right
which corresponds to 10 second of audio
data and that
is embedded so very cool we just append
it to our list i'm just showing a
counter just to see the size of our data
set
and then yeah that's it so we have like
around 2 000 files that are that are
processed which is great we have like
over 2 000 records for
music to play with now i'm now storing
all of this i'm dumping all of this into
a json file
and this music set json is now our
formatted data set that we can now use
in our third notebook
for generating recommendations and
that's coming up next
luckily now you don't actually even have
to execute this code
at all because i'm going to provide the
music set json
in uh i think i'm going to provide it in
the repository
uh with the code that's going to be in
the description below it's a huge file i
think it's like 13 megabytes
of just raw data which is cool right and
i'm just like printing it out just so
that you can show see like okay the
first 10
this well this actually doesn't make
sense but this is like the first
for the first example only the first 10
numbers of the 1280
for like four samples of data just to
see if it's working
but honestly you don't really need this
so cool
that worked and notebook number two is
complete
audio processing now before we get into
um this third notebook on uh
annoy right let me explain exactly how
annoy computes
the nearest neighbors with a slide deck
right here
so i'm getting this slide deck from the
creator of uh annoy
i think it's eric byrne he used to work
at spotify during his time at spotify he
built
this annoy index um that helps you find
approximate nearest neighbors
why we want to use approximate nearest
neighbors is that it's much faster than
you know trying to compute
uh i think like you know it just so much
faster than using like
you know let's say if you have 10 000
pieces of music in your data set you
can't just
do a brute force linear scan otherwise
it'll take forever right annoys just
like hundreds of times faster
and so we are going to use an
approximate nearest neighbor algorithm
to get you know
pretty good recommendations so this
x this is an excerpt from a 50 minute
video that he has on youtube
explaining this entire concept but i'm
going to try to distill it down for what
we require for this video so
for that let's get into building the
annoy index so let's say that each of
these points these
x's um here it's like in a vector space
of this is the embedding space by the
way
generated that max buy that max audio
and better um here it's like a
two-dimensional space but let's just
imagine that it was like
i don't know let me open it up let's
imagine that this was
i don't know the the 1280 dimensional
space
but for for the sake of understanding
it's a two-dimensional space
right now how to do this is that you
just pick any random two points
in your embedding and then you draw you
you draw a line between them
and then split that line with a
perpendicular line right
and now we have two separate halves
right here now what you're gonna do is
you're gonna choose two
points in the top in like this region
and two points in this region
split it by two again randomly and
that's what we do here
and you just keep doing that split
selecting you know any random two points
per region
and performing a split until eventually
you get you know these small itty-bitty
box regions
right so you would think that okay well
now this is a partition of
of an embedding space um that you can
also
format as a decision tree right so the
first like node was like all
all of them are there then the first
split would be okay not a decision tree
more like
a binary tree right because
let's see if they have this yeah so this
would be like for example
all all your points are in one when you
perform your first split you you know
you have two regions now
and then you perform two splits each
time right and you keep going down and
down and down
until eventually you'll end up at these
circular leaf nodes
which basically correspond to you know
these individual like this individual
region
of you know points and these three
points are within those leaf nodes
right so yeah
now when you're searching for a point um
yeah so now let's say that you want to
search for a particular
a search for let's say that now you you
want to give your
um this annoy like a vector right and
you want to find the nearest neighbors
itself so what do you do
so let's say that the the actual point
in the embedding space lies somewhere
here
right where this white x is so you think
okay should i just
just traverse the tree which is
corresponding to just that region so
should we just recommend
um you know points within the this
corresponds to a leaf in the decision
tree
should we just correspond to you know
should we just like return these
but there's a problem with this because
there might be some points here like you
can see like these
x's over here that are very close to
this
particular point too but they're not
being recommended to you because they're
in a totally different
um area but all of this happened
arbitrarily because of a random split
and so um there are situations where you
know when you're
choosing the two points to create the
split the distance between those points
could be extremely small
and so if it is small we want to
traverse both sides of the tree
that's what they do here so let's say
that okay you have this is the main
thing
you choose to split you you then have
two regions here
and now our main point actually lies
here right
but the thing is when we're making the
split right over here
let's say that the split is between two
points that we're taking
by random chance right all this happens
randomly is going to be extremely close
to each other
it's lower than some threshold and
because of that okay because it's lower
than some threshold
we want to traverse both of these trees
because
you know that's a kind of where like
just to make sure that we're getting all
of the points that are encapsulating
you know both regions so we not only
have this region but we also have like
some one two three four five other
regions that could potentially be our
nearest neighbors
right and so if you kind of highlight
all of these five regions
in the actual space you get something
like this
where we have you know all these five
regions and then we have the main region
so basically
what it's saying is that if we pass in
something like an embedding some random
piece of music that is at x this red x
it'll be recommending
all the points in this region right and
that's pretty cool
so yay cool we were able to do that now
the thing with this is that
um the implement implementation wise so
you can
uh let me look at this so this entire
thing right
all this entire tree in general and this
entire searching for
this nearest neighbor can be implemented
by using
heaps and a priority queue well heaps
which are implemented sorry
priority queues which are implemented by
heaps and with priority queues
you have basically a struct where you
know a weight is given
to every single node right and you sort
it by well this
this part is a little opaque to me
honestly so i really do suggest you to
watch his video for
specifically the implementation of the
priority queue but essentially what's
happening is that
it's just another way to extract the
nearest neighbors
kind of like we see in uh
this graph right that's it
now the thing is that a problem that
we're facing here now is that
well um so the problem that we're facing
here is that this
this is formed by just one tree like for
example if this is like the embedding
space that we got it was
we get one tree and we have like a set
of nearest neighbors but this is just
like
one example and it's always better to
have multiple
trees like this we can build multiple
trees like this so that you know that
by random chance you know we won't be
missing certain points and the more
trees we build and we take all of
these trees into consideration when
making the decision for
determining nearest neighbors it becomes
a lot
more concrete so for example let's say
with all the random splits on the same
data set
we get this set of points right for the
nearest neighbors red x's
like probably are the music that we put
in and then the
all the nearest neighbors are within
these this purple region
and then with the same set of points
we're going to perform annoy again we're
going to do that random splits
but then this time we get splits over
here and then the last time again we're
going to do it
this is like a third time over here so
because of that we have like
i don't know let's say that we wanted to
recommend 10 songs for each
for each right so that means like there
will be 10 in this recommended 10 here
10 here and they may be overlapping but
then we use all of this combined
together in order to make a decision of
which ones to actually surface as the
nearest neighbors
so i think that's going to be more clear
over
here right so basically what we do um
the steps that annoy takes is that well
we'll basically um search all trees
until we have k items so in this k
items is like let's say that we wanted
to build
a recommender where we input a piece of
music and we output 10 recommended items
in that case let's take k to be 10 items
here right
so every single tree that we construct
will output
10 items so let's say if we do 50 trees
i think in the code you'll see that i do
50 trees
so each of those 50 trees will do 10
items which means that we have 500 items
overall
but now if you take the union and remove
duplicates there's definitely going to
be a lot of duplicates because annoy
itself is already
pretty you know even with one tree it's
going to get pretty good examples so i
wouldn't be surprised
if all the other trees regardless of the
random split would surface similar
recommendations
and so let's say from a 500 um
i don't know it distills down to like
500 but like 400 of them are duplicates
it distills down to around 100
points now that we can use and now
since it's only like 100 points we can
actually compute raw distances for every
single one of those hundred points from
our um the query uh vector which is
the music that we want recommendations
for and it's it's not too
bad so once we do that then we can sort
them in a ranked order of
nearest neighbors or the nearest
distances and all of that i think is
represented visible
visually here so you have three decision
trees when our case will have like 50.
we find the candidates
each of the leaves contain like maybe 10
um
examples 10 pieces of neighbors
then you get the union of all of these
so which would probably be like 100
like guys mentioned before removing all
the duplicates you find the nearest
neighbors for all of those hundred from
the query point which is our
vector that we want the recommendations
for and then we can
rank them to find their nearest 100
neighbors or the nearest 10 neighbors or
whatever that is
right and that's it that is
the entire nearest neighbor algorithm
with annoy using finding approximate
nearest neighbors and you'll find that
this is
blazing fast right so
with that intuition in mind and i hope
that was a
a respectable uh explanation you can
always watch his video just to get some
more context but i think this is enough
for this video
and it's also a 50 minute video so i'm
saving you some time
now let's build the recommender with
annoy very easy
so first of all the objective is to get
the top 10 recommendations for
a piece of input music so right now
we uh we need to cr for this to run this
notebook you need the music.json file
from the previous notebook and then you
can run this notebook
but i'll provide it for you so first
install annoy
now i need this literal eval because
like i'm reading from
a json file and i want to make sure that
all of it is in a json structured manner
you'll see that actually right here when
i'm reading the json file
and right now i am reading the class
labels
from that csv that i showed earlier this
uh the csv with all the
categories and classes
and let's go back where is that yeah
so yeah and then um yeah just
um yeah you could say i'm just doing i'm
creating a dictionary out of it so it's
like
one would be speech two would be you
know whatever
male talking or something like that just
to create a dictionary so it's easy to
access
um now i'm taking the once i read the
json file i'm taking the length of the
data set like i said it's a 2000 example
so we have
2 000 pieces of music to play with now
this is the meat of the code right here
and this is all you really need for
annoy uh basically it's saying okay i
want to create an annoy index
where we now need to pass in the number
of dimensions
that each of our samples is which is
1280.
um the length of the vector will be
indexed yeah cool
um then for every single uh
you know every single piece of music in
this we want to
add it to the index we've also basically
we're saying hey
these are the samples we want you you to
use to
to kind of like find the nearest
neighbors of so this is our entire world
right now i could only pass in 1 000 of
these 2071 examples because
otherwise it'll crash the program um a
way to
to kind of uh you know get rid of that
uh
this barrier is probably to decrease its
dimensions which you can do with other
you know maybe like other dimensionality
reduction techniques but even with a
thousand i think that this is
perfectly fine it'll work fine right
so now for every single one of these i
want to get the corresponding data
which will be the you know the actual
vector of 1280
dimensions and we add that vector with
an index so i'm just indexing as you
know one two three four all the way
and we're just adding it to our annoy
index
next we want to build it so basically
what build is going to do
is the the heavy lifting of like
creating those splits
random slips like 50 times we create
those trees that we talked about
like i said we have 50 of those trees
the more the better
um it just gets you a more accurate
representation of the best nearest
neighbors and most
makes the more approximate nearest
neighbors less approximate and more
actual
so for more accuracy you can use a
higher number of trees
to build the index and then you can save
the nearest neighbors in a graph in an a
n file so cool that's done
now when you want to get the nearest
neighbors well
here i'm indexing every item let's say
that i want to get the nearest neighbors
for
item number 193 in the index like that
we built here
so item number 193 i want to get that
index
and um i want to get the 10
nearest neighbors for this index right
this is what we're
yeah so i want to build an index
and get the 10 nearest neighbors for
that index
um okay cool right and what i'm doing
right here now
uh i know like 193 is like a weird
number but that's why i've also like
printed out the entire music data set
within that index like all the 1000
examples so that you can see
exactly like okay here's the index and
here's the kind of
um the labels that are actually given to
it so you can kind of compare
okay 193 that's like uh
it's opera music okay so opera music
that's
just for intuition so that you can
understand right and now what we do is
now we have this nearest neighbor index
for
this will be like the nearest neighbors
and i'll store it here and what i'm
doing for every single one of these
nearest neighbors i just want to print
it out
right and that's what i'm doing so the
first nearest neighbor of course
is the 193 which is obvious because that
is the same
music that we input to the data set so
obviously it's the closest because it
will overlap
but the second one is this so it's
basically saying
let me explain every single one of these
parts so each part
of these nearest these are the ten
nearest neighbors each part is four
things in it this is the index within
annoy internally
this is the set of tags that are given
to that piece of music
this is the uh this is actually the
youtube url that you can use to google
it and i'll show you right now actually
and this is the starting and ending
timestamps in seconds
so let's look at this first one here
right x t g
m r l o whatever this is right so if you
go to that youtube video
that's right here i paste it right here
and we want to start
at 30 to 40 seconds right 30 seconds to
40 seconds
is the clip so that's this
let's start
something like that right i'm not
playing more because of copyright
but you you kind of heard that right
pretty good opera music
and then um so that's the input
and that's also the first um closest
neighbor but
the the actual close versus neighbor
which it would have been is this song is
this one so
it's this video at whatever this k9t
thing is
at 80 to 90 seconds so i think that's
this video
yeah k9c right here and then
at 80 seconds is uh basically uh you
know whatever
one minute 20 seconds so
let's play that
[Music]
pretty good right so they are actually
pretty close to each other
and what you can do is you don't even
need to use just
um i'm just using recycling like
whatever is in my index to find the
nearest neighbors
what you can do actually in in actual
usage is that you can
encode you take your raw wav file and
you can encode it
using this um this audio set
um yeah this audio set processing uh
actually not the audience
this demo file yes you can encode it
using this demo file just by calling
that curl command
on your wav file kind of like this and
then it'll output
a set of um and then you can get like
the embeddings information
and then you can use that embedding in
um this
annoy notebook right here and
in order to to like feed it into our
nearest into
into this this thing right here so here
i'm getting nearest neighbor by item but
you can also get nearest nato
neighbor by vector so you'll be passing
in the vector that you just created
and you can get like as many nearest
neighbors as you want to from the
embedding set obviously i can only get a
thousand because there's only a thousand
here
but yeah that's that's pretty much it
right and that's if you understood this
well i mean this is
all of it three notebooks three
resources um i'm gonna put all of this
down in the description below
everything is going to be up on github
the link to that will be in the
description down below
along with the class label csv as well
as the data set if i can get it uploaded
i'm sure like 12 megabytes is not too
bad
but i hope this was helpful i hope you
all
learned something um understood
something hope the explanations weren't
too
out of the way i know that priority
queue implementation um
is a little hazy but other than that
you can read their entire github too for
more information please do subscribe
uh write some comments um start a
discussion in the description
in the you know description down below
in the comments down below oh god
long videos what i'm gonna do okay well
i'm gonna see you later okay
just do do what you gotta do bye